[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] وبينما نتحدث عن omicron ، دعونا
لا ننسى أيضًا أن البديل السائد في
الوقت الحالي لا يزال هو
متغير دلتا ،
لذا قد يكون omicron في ازدياد وقد نصل
إلى نقطة حيث يتولى الأمر  أن
تكون هو البديل السائد ولكن في هذه
المرحلة
يظل الشكل السائد للغاية دلتا
[موسيقى]
، من المستحسن جدًا أن
يبدأ مصنعو اللقاح بالفعل في التخطيط
مسبقًا والتخطيط لاحتمالية
الاضطرار إلى تعديل
اللقاح الموجود ، وهو أمر جيد
ليس فقط الانتظار حتى موعد  حتى
يدق جرس الإنذار الأخير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نحتاج إلى أن نكون مستعدين وحذرًا
وهذا شيء قلناه
منذ بداية الوباء
ليس ذعرًا
لأننا اليوم في وضع مختلف
عما كنا عليه في  في بداية
عام 2020 ، لدينا أدوات نعرف ما يجب القيام به ،
ونعرف ما
يناسبك [الموسيقى]